You have probably heard of the beauty of Ha Long Bay in Vietnam or at least seen a picture...
...where the magic meeting of land and sea may have impressed you.
It has been attracting more visitors since its UNESCO recognition.
Do you wonder what Ha Long means?
It can be translated into "Bay of Descending Dragons."
You might take a picture of a possibly dragon-shaped rock formation there.
The area is home to many fishing communities...
...who live on floating houses and boats, which give it a vibrant energy.
The bay is sprinkled with a dense cluster of almost 2,000 limestone...
...monolithic islands topped with thick jungle vegetation...
...that rise out of the ocean in a most spectacular way.
Some of the islands are actually hollow and contain huge caves.
French tourists called the largest one "Grotte des Merveilles."
It has three large chambers full of stalactites and stalagmites, plus 19th century French graffiti.
Isn't that interesting?